Speaker 1: So I want to start today with the
vaccination and the Delta variant and some
really, really ignorant stuff continuing to
come out of I mean, I guess we have to call
it at least tacitly anti vaccine media.
Fox hosts on Fox and Friends can't understand
why President Joe Biden is so focused on getting
Americans vaccinated and on getting vaccines
to people around the world in other countries.
Now, last week, I did a segment where I explained,
I really hate politics, not because I lack
passion about the issues, but because so much
of our time has to be spent preventing really
ignorant people, bad people in some cases,
from actively doing damage to the country.
And here is a perfect example of this.
Right now, we are engaged in a battle against
a virus and a highly contagious Delta variant
and against anti vaccines as well to truly
end this pandemic.
We're not just fighting the virus.
We're fighting the anti vaccines as well,
the so-called covid truthers.
Unfortunately, some countries do not yet have
enough vaccines.
That's a very specific problem.
But just as unfortunately we do have enough
vaccines, but we have a huge portion of our
population in the US that just doesn't want
one.
And our ability to defeat this pandemic now
comes down so simply.
I mean, it couldn't be any simpler.
Just get vaccinated, vaccinate as quickly
as possible.
And on Fox News, their minds are just boggled
by Joe Biden working really proactively on
vaccination.
Why won't he stop working on vaccination?
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Meanwhile, Simmons head to the
top of the hour.
They're one of the big stories have been with
us for last two years is covid-19.
The origin is the top story.
But the but the focus of this administration
on vaccination is mind boggling.
GLIKSON And many cases they've done a very
good job getting the word out and getting
the vaccine out from Johnson Johnson to Pfizer
and Moderna.
They're available if you want them, but that's
not enough.
Now, you need to be berated by none other
than Dr. Fauci because you're playing politics.
That's the reason you may have not gotten
it.
Speaker 3: Listen, this is not complicated.
We're not asking anybody to make any political
statement one way or another.
We're saying try and save your life and that
of your family and that of the community.
Speaker 1: It's mind boggling, guys.
And look at Brian Kilmeade even saying, you
know, some people might not want to get vaccinated
because they're being encouraged.
If you just left them alone, is the implication,
maybe they would go and get themselves vaccinated.
It's like an insanely childish reverse psychology
to get people vaccinated, to save their own
lives or the lives of people they love or
people in their communities.
You have to go to the childish, oh, you can't
have this little Jimmy.
Oh, really?
Oh, I want it.
Then give me the thing you're telling me I
can't have.
And this is why things are now looking so
rough.
I can't believe this is happening, but cases
are going way up here in the United States.
I cases are up almost 50 percent, 50 percent
cases are up in the last ten days in Spain.
Spain really had this under control.
Cases are up 360 percent.
Measures are quickly being put back in place
in the United Kingdom.
That's one of the sport's earliest hit by
the Delta variant.
Daily cases are up fourteen hundred percent.
Now, of course, the good news, depending on
your perspective, is that it's mostly unvaccinated
people that are getting infected right now.
Now, you might say, well, that's good news
in the sense that it means the vaccines work.
Well, the problem is not everybody can get
vaccinated yet in some countries because they
don't yet have vaccines in some countries
because they're too young to qualify.
But but that's not that's not everybody, right?
I mean, six to eight percent of people of
normal health will get a vaccine and not develop
immunity.
And there are breakthrough cases.
More and more of them are the Delta variant
and some of those vaccinated people are going
to get hit as well.
And in the meantime, as cases are up 50 percent
in the United States, Fox News can't figure
out why is so Biden so focused on vaccination
as if it's a bad thing?
We are really in trouble as a country and
I don't expect this to get any better.
They seem to be digging in and forget about
Delta.
We're soon going to have LAMDA.
I don't even want to guess at this point.
I'm not even going to think about it yet what
things are going to look like in the United
States
in the
fall